et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
donc Christian Campbon bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin
sénateur la républicain du Val-de-Marne
vous êtes le président ici au Sénat de
la commission des affaires étrangères de
la défense et des forces armées pendant
20 minutes pour interview en partenariat
avec la presse quotidienne régionale
bonjour Stéphane Vernet
Christian Cambon ce matin quand vous
voyez ce qui se passe en Ukraine avec
des bombardements dans la capitale Kiev
est-ce que vous comprenez quel est le
but de guerre de Vladimir Poutine bah le
but de guerre il est très simple c'est
de mettre à genoux l'Ukraine de
faire le siège de Kiev de s'emparer
vraisemblablement de Monsieur zilinski
de toute son équipe qu'il traite de
nazis
et il va lui organiser un procès c'est
les méthodes de absolument classiques
qui
soviétique et bien évidemment c'est
mettre la main sur
sur l'Ukraine parce que l'Ukraine a
commis le péché
majeur un pays qui est à Mayenne lors de
Maydan voulait se tourner vers
l'Occident voulait vivre en liberté et
en démocratie et ça monsieur Poutine ne
le tolère pas et la manière dont il gère
son pays le montre alex est
la manière dont il traite son opposition
monsieur Navali est en prison pour des
années
on fait assassiner des gens à
l'extérieur
nous avons reçu des signes très nombreux
devant lesquels l'Occident n'a pas su
donner me semble-t-il toute l'importance
qu'il convenait on a eu la Crimée on a
eu ce qui s'est passé en Transnistrie en
a quasi en oscétie tout ça nous paraît
très lointain et il y a dans l'Occident
un sentiment qui consiste à dire que
tout ça n'est pas important que tout ça
ce sont faire ils sont très complexes et
qui date de longtemps mais
malheureusement les signes étaient très
forts
ils n'ont pas voulu voir ils n'ont pas
souvent
on a tenté Sarkozy a été en Géorgie et
puis on aurait dû continuer on aurait dû
peut-être aussi plus dialoguer au moment
où c'était encore possible il y a un
Poutine 1 et un Poutine 2 le président
de la République lui-même le dit celui
qui l'a rencontré l'autre jour n'a plus
rien à voir avec celui de Versailles et
de Brégançon donc
Vladimir Poutine Emmanuel Macron l'a
appelé hier soir
je pense ce que dit président de la
République
[Musique]
réside le Conseil européen pour
l'instant donc ça me semble pas anormal
mais je pense qu'il n'y a rien à
attendre de ces entretiens du reste
quand on décrypte le communiquer
l'entretien a été franc et très court
alors donc je pense que ça a dû durer 2
minutes et d'autres
pour lui dire je continue car le plan se
déroule
de manière infaillible tout ce qui est
tout ce que l'on constate aujourd'hui
est effectivement été prévisible et on
n'a pas voulu le prévoir et on n'a pas
voulu le voir
j'ai une question concernant les chefs
d'État qui ont concerné
Vladimir Poutine ces derniers mois 10
tout ce que il a il a changé d'attitude
en fait c'était plus le même homme
aujourd'hui il parle de des nazifié
l'Ukraine de génocide et qui qui croit
encore à ces histoires est-ce que est-ce
que lui-même on est persuadé et est-ce
que est-ce que les Russes souvent le
suivre sur ce terrain là il est sûr
qu'il y a une évolution psychologique
qui
qui se constate à travers par exemple
les mensonges qu'il adresse j'entendais
ce matin tôt le compte rendu d'une
réunion qu'il a eu avec des chaises
d'entreprise en disant c'est c'était la
seule manière c'était la seule manière
de nous défendre il prétend maintenant
que c'est l'Ukraine qui allait attaquer
la Russie donc tout le monde sait très
bien que c'est une folie traiter ces
gens de nazi comment un pays qui a
autant souffert des nazis peut-il
comparer le régime de monsieur qui n'est
sûrement pas à l'abri de toute critique
mais comment
prétendre que ces gens sont des nazis or
je crois que malheureusement dans une
opinion russe qui est véritablement
fermé à toute influence extérieure les
gens finissent par le croire peut
fonctionner mais bien sûr que ça doit
fonctionner
jusqu'à la Pologne par exemple
c'est-à-dire jusqu'à ce qu'on arrête et
on va l'arrêter aux limites de l'OTAN
puisque là pour le coup les pays qui
sont membres de l'OTAN eux bénéficient
de l'article 5 c'est-à-dire la
solidarité de l'ensemble des membres de
l'OTAN si jamais ils sont agressés
malheureusement l'Ukraine ne faisait pas
partie de l'OTAN et donc il ne peut pas
y avoir la mise en œuvre de cet article
5 et c'est pour ça que on ne peut
envoyer on ne peut pas envoyer de
troupes à ce titre là mais je pense que
Poutine ira jusqu'à ce qu'on arrête il
ne croit qu'on rapporte de force
à la Lituanie à l'Estonie ou à la
Roumanie les choses vont changer de où
vont changer de niveau parce que
évidemment le temps ne va pas rester
inerte dans cette histoire
automatiquement dans une troisième
guerre mondiale
c'est un risque il faut mieux le savoir
et il faut pas se il faut pas jouer la
politique de l'autruche en disant plus
rien ne va arriver on a passé son temps
du président Poutine l'entraînerait
jusqu'à des actions
qui sont nouveaux on risque par exemple
de subir y compris peut-être en France
des cyberattaques massives moi vous
savez quand je vais dans les pays baltes
j'entends un pays comme la Lituanie qui
subit 57000 à Taxe cyber pendant un
weekend il y a plus de système
hospitalier le système le weekend
suivant il y a plus système bancaire on
peut avoir ça souvenez-vous de ce qu'il
a dit avant-hier ceux qui s'opposent à
ce que je suis en train de faire en
Ukraine connaîtront des choses d'une
violence telle qu'ils n'ont jamais connu
auparavant
avec la Russie doivent savoir que la
réponse de la Russie sera immédiate et
conduira des conséquences que vous
n'avez encore jamais connues
jusqu'à
la mise en œuvre d'attaque cyber qui
peuvent être très handicapantes très
dangereuse tout aussi dangereuse qu'une
intervention évidemment on envisage pas
aujourd'hui que la France reçoivent des
bombes mais il faut se préparer et je
sais que
l'état-major les états majors de l'OTAN
celui l'état-major français bien
évidemment se prépare toutes nos forces
sont actuellement en alerte
puisque face à quelqu'un
il s'y prépare sûrement je n'ai pas le
détail de ce qu'ils font et si je l'ai
je ne peux pas le dire mais ce que je
peux vous dire c'est qu'effectivement on
se prépare dorénavant à toute
éventualité parce que lorsque vous avez
affaire à quelqu'un qui fonctionne d'une
avec dans une manière tellement
erratique et tellement folle il faut se
préparer à tout le président de la
République a été très clair et moi je le
soutiens dans cette phrase il dit je
vais protéger les Français dans toutes
les circonstances nous avons les moyens
nous protéger nous avons des forces
armées nous avons des services de
renseignement nous avons des services de
sécurité visant à protéger nos
installations informatiques il faut
mettre tout ça en eux car vous ne savez
pas ce qui peut arriver alors il s'agit
pas de créer la panique générale mais il
faut il faut rester
attentifs contre Vladimir Poutine on va
y venir mais il a aussi dit l'Alliance
atlantique est aussi une alliance
nucléaire comme un message adressé à
Vladimir Poutine nous aussi
monsieur Poutine c'est très bien
qu'effectivement au sein de l'Alliance
lunaire il y a des il y a des puissances
nucléaires dont la France la France est
dotée d'un système de dissuasion
nucléaire et comme son nom l'indique la
diffusion c'est généralement pour ne pas
s'en servir c'est pas anormal c'est pas
normal même si je trouve que le propos
était un petit peu un petit peu fort
parce que non mais il s'agit pas non
plus de créer un moment de panique moi
on m'appelle on me dit mais ce qu'il
faut se protéger est-ce qu'il faut
partir et cetera non on n'est pas là
mais il faut se tenir prêt il faut se
tenir prêt la France est prête
nos forces classiques nos forces
nucléaires sont sous alerte nous
participons à des opérations de l'OTAN
nous allons très vraisemblablement aussi
renforcer notre
dispositifs qu'en Roumanie on va envoyer
un certain nombre de contingent pour
être DCP avant que ce soit trop tard
quel regard est-ce que vous portez sur
le train de sanction qui a été annoncé
hier
ils ont toutes les ressources qu'ils
veulent alors on parle aussi de
transaction de sanction sur les
transactions financières notamment le
fait de sortir du système Swift qui est
un système de transaction
des transactions notamment sur les
matières premières se faisait avec la
Russie en dollars elles ne sont plus à
10 % en contrepartie ils avaient 240
tonnes d'or ils en ont 2600 tonnes donc
je veux dire c'est là où l'on voit et on
aurait dû être plus attentif à toutes
ces mesures qui les unes après les
autres formes comme un poste donc
maintenant on comprend effectivement
l'efficacitées
l'interdiction de la réduction la moitié
des exportations de semi-conducteurs
en plus
qui va les aider c'est les Chinois qui
sont très heureux de la manière dont les
choses se passent qui se donne la
possibilité vis-à-vis de la Russie dont
il craignait un certain nombre de
mesures ils vont trouver un appui auprès
des Chinois qui vont vraisembloux
moi je crois que pour l'instant au jour
où nous parlons quand on a affaire à
quelqu'un qui agit de la sorte il faut
s'attendre effectivement à au
regroupement de de tous ces états qui
refusent l'application du droit
international alors il y a aussi des
petits craquements vous savez que dans
dans quelques minutes nous allons avoir
cette conférence des 27 pays européens
qui viennent ici au Sénat pour parler de
la sécurité et de la défense la date
était prévue depuis longtemps c'est un
hasard invraisemblable qui fait que ça
se tient aujourd'hui or qui avons-nous
vu hier soir arriver dans les
délégations nous avons vu la délégation
turque et qui vraisemblablement votre a
la déclaration finale que je vais
proposer au nom du Président au vote
tout à l'heure donc vous voyez que il
faut aussi regarder comment les choses
se passent parce que c'est agitation ne
plaît pas non plus à tout le monde et
donc il va falloir regarder
quels sont celles et ceux qui restent
encore dans le
campus
même si elles sont sévères elle ne sait
pas elle ne servent à rien parce que
Vladimir Poutine s'y était préparé voir
elles peuvent se retourner contre les
Européens
les sanctions qui ont été prises dans le
domaine agroalimentaire on fusillé des
filières comme la filière porcine la
vente de volaille de pommes etc il y a
des marchés entiers que nous avons perdu
et qui ne reviendront jamais car la
Russie est Poutine a véritablement mis
en œuf ce plan machiavélique
et même d'autres pays moi vous savez je
prés France Maroc et nos amis marocains
disent continuer à prendre des sanctions
contre la contre la Russie alors nous ça
nous ouvre
les pays de les 27 ne sont pas du tout
dépendants de la même manière à ces
importations les Autrichiens le sont
extrêmement les Allemands très très
fortement nous beaucoup moins est-ce que
le fait de pas être sur le même pied par
rapport à cette consommation là fait que
les pays d'Europe pourraient avoir être
tenté de ne pas adopter les mêmes
positions d'avoir de parler d'une même
voix il est sûr qu'il va y avoir des
tensions je trouve que pour l'instant la
réponse donnée par l'Allemagne qui
suspend le fameux Nord Stream 2 qui est
évidemment une source
d'approvisionnement de gaz direct vers
l'Allemagne vers l'Allemagne bon c'est
déjà assez courageux mais comme vous le
dit très justement tout le monde n'est
pas logé à la même enseigne et c'est là
où du reste sur le plan intérieur on
retrouve le débat concernant l'autonomie
énergétique car si nous nous n'avions
pas 75% du courant qui est fabriqué par
l'énergie atomique l'énergie nucléaire
et bien nous n'en serions pas là et nous
serions peut-être nous aussi victimes de
ce chantage et il était donc tout à fait
invraisemblable d'imposer des sanctions
à la Russie alors que dans le même temps
un certain nombre de pays tels que
l'Allemagne leur acheter son énergie si
vous voulez il y a quelque chose d'un
peu schizophrène dans ce comportement
et qui nous disait mais l'Ukraine elle a
renoncé à s'équiper de l'arme nucléaire
parce qu'on lui a promis qu'on allait
assurer sa sécurité
dans le monde est-ce que vous partagez
cette inquiétude écoutez moi je n'en
suis pas là pour l'instant d'abord parce
que ce sont des dépenses qui coûtent
effroyablement cher nous sommes nous
actuellement en train dans le cadre de
la loi de programmation militaire de
dépenser de l'argent simplement pour
maintenir à niveau nos forces nucléaires
notamment notre nucléaire qui depuis
plus de 60 ans 365 jours par an équipé
de 16 têtes circulent quelque part dans
le monde c'est de la dissuasion
s'équiper se rééquiper d'une force
nucléaire surtout dans les conditions
ils vont se trouver je pense que c'est
assez compliqué alors non je crois que
c'était une perte de crédibilité
de l'Ukraine où on dit maintenant vous
occupez pas de l'arme nucléaire on va
vous protéger ils vont dire maintenant
on va s'équiper c'est pas le cas on sera
pas protégé
avec l'Iran on le voit bien avec un
certain nombre d'autres pays et il faut
être assez vigilant pour faire en sorte
que le club des des puissances
nucléaires ne s'élargissent pas parce
que
aujourd'hui
il faut le surveiller parce que si
l'arme nucléaire est dans la main de de
pays voyou là les deux de graves drames
risque de nous toucher bien évidemment
Emmanuel Macron hier soir
à la mi-journée pour être plus précise
il a dit les sanctions portées à la
Russie seront à la hauteur de
l'agression dont elle se rend coupable
sur le plan militaire et économique nous
serons sans faiblesse militaire ça veut
dire quoi pour vous
savez c'est du responsable que nous il y
a une grande désillusion parce que nous
avons travaillé avec les Russes le Sénat
ici a maintenu le dialogue coûte que
coûte ce n'était pas facile mais nous
avons essayé d'échanger sur cette
thématique et il y avait effectivement à
l'époque des points de convergence
notamment dans le domaine spatial dans
le domaine scientifique avait des
coopérations je mets de côté du reste
tout ce qui relève de la culture des
universités puisque c'est quand même un
pays dont nous sommes proches sur le
plan culturel et avec une histoire
une histoire commune sur certains nombre
de points il y avait des il y avait des
échanges regarder par exemple dans le
domaine érospatial il y a beaucoup de
cosmos français qui sont partis sur sur
des vols soviétiques vers la station
intern alors je pense que tout ça est
arrêté maintenant il y a des éléments de
coopération militaire notamment ceux qui
relevait de la lutte contre le
terrorisme qui vont qui vont s'arrêter
car il faut bien comprendre aussi que
Monsieur Poutine va se faire un mal
considérable vis-à-vis de l'opinion
internationale on vit quand même et
quelque chose d'absolument
va regarder de manière très différente
et je ne sais pas dans quelle mesure sa
population ne finira pas par comprendre
que on lui ment et qu'on lui raconte des
choses qui n'existent pas le président
de la République a lancé cette nuit
française en Roumanie est-ce que notre
armée parce que l'armée française et
calibré et en capacité de d'entrer dans
un conflit classique sans parler de
conflit nucléaire avec les Russes et
quelles autres pays au sein de l'Union
européenne on a capacité à le faire
aujourd'hui soyons clairs
nucléaire et si brusquement la Russie
menacée avec l'arme nucléaire
aux marges de l'Ukraine est-ce que la
France est-ce que l'armée française est
en capacité d'intervenir est-ce qu'elle
en est moyen et quelles autres pays en
Europe auraient les moyens de faire ça
le seul pays qui est capable
de projection tel que l'armée française
c'est l'armée britannique est-ce que
l'armée britannique est capable de le
faire est-ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
[Musique]
l'Italie l'Espagne sont pas du tout
calibrés pour ce genre de choses
les forces de réassurance que nous avons
stationné dans les pays balgies
très rassurante si vous voulez lorsqu'il
y a pas d'affrontement mais qui bien
évidemment face à l'arrivée de 20000 ou
30000 soldats
russe ne tiendrait pas très longtemps la
même chose en Roumanie la Roumanie nous
demande de renforcer
sa défense et la défense de ses
frontières nous allons vraiment y aller
avec un contingent qui va être discuté
700 800000 on n'en sais rien 700 800 ou
1000 pas 800000 bien sûr avec aussi des
de l'équipement lourd blindé et cetera
bon si vous voulez c'est c'est aussi un
signe d'avertissement c'est de dire si
vous touchez à la Roumanie là pour le
coup on sera sur place pour être
solidaire et encore une fois
le temps
répond à d'autres règles si vous voulez
que ce malheureux pays d'Ukraine qui se
trouve bien seul comme l'a dit Monsieur
Zelinski cette nuit car justement
qu'il faut envoyer des armes la seule
chose on fait comment on fait comment il
y a déjà plus d'aéroport je crois qu'il
y a un seul aéroport qui fonctionne donc
vous allez envoyer un à 400 m chargé de
charger de munition mais peut-être qu'il
le but des Russes notamment par la
neutralisation
ukrainien donc vous allez pas y aller
vous avez pas envoyé trois wagons de
munition ça va être très compliqué mais
bien évidemment si on peut le faire il
faut le faire il lui fallut faire du
reste un peu plus tôt
un mot sur la on va passer à la
présidentielle peut-être pour pour
terminer vous avez un certain nombre de
candidats par exemple qui disent vouloir
sortir du commandement intégrer de
l'OTAN est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez ah ben ils ont bien compris le
sujet alors franchement on peut leur en
même temps le président de la République
lui-même avait parlé de de l'OTAN comme
étant en état de mort cérébrale
le président de la République se
plaignait justement des faiblesses de
l'OTAN les autres disent il faut sortir
de l'OTAN c'est pas exactement
bien compris le sujet qu'elle faisait
des déclarations de tendresse à
l'endroit de Monsieur Poutine et on voit
ce que ça donne alors maintenant
brusquement ils ont disparu de la
circulation
effectivement
j'entendais des des recoupements de
déclaration de monsieur Zemmour par
exemple sur sur Poutine le comparant à
nos plus grand chef militaire et
président le général de Gaulle je trouve
que franchement c'est indécent et
maintenant on voit tout simplement que
leurs analyses sont mauvaises maintenant
aux Français de juger les Français ne
sont pas bêtes vous savez alors Valérie
n'a pas changé de pied sur cette
question par contre il y a un souci
c'est le le l'attitude de François
Fillon
j'ai entendu des choses de sa propre
bouche qui m'ont véritablement
scandalisé donc nous en restons là pour
l'instant monsieur Fillon fait ce qu'il
veut il est rémunéré par des grands
groupes
russes c'est son choix et il a le droit
il faut lui reconnaître le droit d'avoir
quitter la politique et de faire des
affaires
et de nombreux dirigeants d'Europe
centrale ancien des anciens ministres et
des anciens Premier ministre qui ont été
captés par les Russes et qui sont
rémunérés dans tout un tas de
d'entreprises moi c'est pas totalement
ma philosophie
j'ai entendu des choses dans une réunion
qui ne m'ont pas plus du tout voilà et
que je considère que François Fillon
n'est pas le plus qualifié pour
s'exprimer sur ces sujets maintenant
il y a une prise de parole hier place de
la République à Paris suite à l'appel de
l'Union des des
Ukrainiens de France et donc une dame
qui est en direct dénoncer la propagande
russe et le mal que la propagande russe
faisait à l'Ukraine y compris en France
elle parle des influenceurs qui sont
achetés des médias qui se payent Poutine
du de l'ensemble du du discours qui est
diffusé y compris dans notre pays est-ce
que il faut interdire RT par exemple en
France est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire par rapport à par rapport à ça ce
que vous partagez ce constat une vraie
propagande qui se développe dans ce pays
comment on peut comment on peut la
contrebalancer déjà il faudrait mieux
expliquer le rôle de recherche today et
de Spoutnik les deux moyens
d'information qui petit à petit gagne
des parts de marché en Europe du reste
il faut regarder comment les liens
fonctionnent on voit que recherche
donc tout ça est très intéressant à
savoir donc déjà on pourrait l'expliquer
et puis faut-il interdire moi
personnellement je suis assez peu
favorable à l'interdiction des moyens de
communication parce que d'abord vous
aurez des mesures en retour et donc
peut-être que vous-même les journalistes
vous n'aurez plus accès à la Russie ou à
l'Ukraine alors qu'on a absolument
besoin de votre travail pour expliquer
ce qui se passe mais il faut savoir que
il y a des influenceurs qu'il y a des
gens qui effectivement portent
subrepticement un message prorus et bah
évidemment quand vous le savez si
j'achète un journal politique
particulièrement orienté à gauche
puisque ce n'est pas mon camp je sais ce
que j'achète et donc c'est peut-être
dans ce qu'il faut aller et le dénoncer
dénoncer effectivement les mensonges car
les mensonges sont très graves et puis
maintenir malgré tout des canaux parce
que il faudra un jour que tout ça
s'arrête il faudra se reparler c'est
difficile pour l'instant mais c'est
quand même vers la paix que nous allons
travailler
merci beaucoup merci Christian
[Musique]